[Music]
daddy where's mommy I can't find mommy
where is she I don't know go play baby
baby daddy's busy Eminem and hailey
Mathers still have a strong relationship
it's okay go with hailey the rapper's 22
year old daughter opened up about her
famous dad in a new interview with Daily
Mail saying quote we are very close
Eminem's fans grew up listening to him
rap about his daughter and the
tumultuous relationship he had with his
ex-wife
Hailey's mom Kim Scott but the Michigan
State University grad who has close to a
million Instagram followers says she's
still figuring out what she wants to do
in the future it's kind of up in the air
while the father/daughter duo haven't
been photographed together in a while
the rapper dedicated his song castle
from his most recent album revival to
his little girl
support you I can barely support me but
as long as you're healthy that's all
that matters for the time being but
obviously assuming you will be just
thinking ahead I'm gonna make it if it
kills me that seal Parkins